this video is sponsored by boxxu which
means we will have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle hello everyone
it is time to talk about the first
episode of the halo tv show of course
this was uh basically inevitable i had
to make this video
just kind of dreading it because
i'm always honest about whatever i feel
about tv or movies or whatever obviously
games as well
um people on youtube get so mad when you
don't like something that they like and
i'm always like i will stay what i
believe regardless
just means people might yell at me for a
few weeks so
like okay let's do it again another one
you didn't like unfortunately it's a
bummer so
i'm a huge halo fan i've been a big halo
fan my entire life um i love halo big
big
i don't know part of my identity at this
point
and it's not like i had high hopes for
this show
um
it had
a tumultuous development i didn't love
some things about the trailer
and a lot of adaptations are kind of bad
um that's not uncommon video game fans
have certainly gotten used to tv
adaptations being kind of bad
so it's not like i wasn't prepared for
that um
however i came away from this one with
kind of a different reaction to what i
expected
so i should preface this by saying
i as someone who has been playing video
games since i could walk basically and
i've been reading comics
for like
almost 20 years
i actually don't generally care when an
on-screen adaptation is different to the
source material i've tried to separate
myself from that i remember when i was a
teenager i cared about that a whole lot
like it mattered and then i i just kind
of grew up it was like you know what
if i wanted it to be exactly the same i
would just play the game
if i wanted the exact same story
or stories i love um like i really like
forward onto dawn
i would just go watch forward unto dawn
again or i would read the comics or read
the halo novels or whatever else i would
just go
watch that stuff i don't need things to
be exactly the same
uh that's not important to me you can
deviate that's fine and that's generally
how i felt about a lot of things um i'm
a really big batman fan and despite what
people in my comments keep trying to
tell me i don't believe any of them have
actually read many batman comics the
recent batman movie
is not very accurate to batman uh in my
opinion
but i was okay with that part that's
fine who cares um it's supposed to be
different halo
i feel like it had like this strange
identity crisis right where
i'm not going to watch any more of this
show um is my thing as i watch this
first episode and it's not like i
thought it was terrible uh there were
things that i thought were interesting i
actually really liked the pacing i felt
like the action was cool i actually
think the plot that they set up was kind
of cool um
even if it's not something that i can
really relate to or understand or see
the chief doing you know if i do the
separation of my head being like this is
a different version of master chief he
doesn't have to be the same
um
it's difficult to understand
someone in that position doing what he's
doing i guess the
thing he picked up whatever we'll get to
the actual details later
but i decided uh
this show
is not something that i i am interested
in ultimately it was like i was like
okay
i get it i'm good
i don't need to watch any more of it
it's not like i thought it was terrible
um
and i was just really surprised to have
that takeaway uh that i think what i
felt was that i wasn't sure who it was
for more than anything else it was like
you've dangled characters i know in
front of me like master chief who you
keep calling mass chief 117 which i
found very jarring and halsey
um and obviously the covenant and the
unsc and like all of these conflicts
that i'm familiar with they just sort of
exist as names
but they aren't the same at all and it
just did something weird that again i'm
usually much better at disconnecting
myself from maybe it's because of how i
feel about halo but i love batman so
much i don't know
that
it just it just felt
like
like you tried to get me interested but
then you were making a show for
completely different people like this
show doesn't feel like it's made for the
video game audience at all
but they still had to
take the correct names and and i just
found it jarring um in a way that's like
usually you get like
out of something like this a little bit
more fan service if they are playing
with the same characters and
it's not a case of me being like why
didn't you make it the same as the fall
of reach you could have told that in
this story i love the fall of reach but
i'm happy to play through reach again i
really like forward unto dawn but i'm
happy to just watch forward unto dawn
again i didn't need a same story retold
i was fine with it not being canon
um just something about the like
mismarriage between
here are these characters we're making
sure that they look accurate we are
keeping their names um their roles are
very similar
however
their personalities are completely
different their motives are completely
different the direction is completely
different it just felt so
like you know two magnets you're trying
to push them together on the wrong ends
and it just like it just doesn't gel for
some reason i just found that so jarring
um
so
it's not made for halo fans is how it
feels and that's fine you can make stuff
for other people that's okay
but then why
wrap it up in these words why not use
completely different characters because
then i might have been more open to it
and it might not have been as difficult
for me to like try to get past
potentially hello everyone it is time to
talk about boksu bok su is a very tasty
japanese snack box subscription service
this is the limited edition 2022
sakuraboxu every year japanese cherry
blossoms bloom all across japan and
people celebrate by gathering under
trees behind me which is flower viewing
and enjoy picnics together which is what
this is in the spirit of they put
together snacks and tea pairings sourced
from all over the country japan that is
that are perfect for your own sakura
celebrations and this packaging is
beautiful this is generally boxus most
anticipated collection of the year it
just has all sorts of cherry blossom
themed
snacks
they're so pretty anyone who subscribes
to boxy during the month of march which
is this month will receive the sakura
season as their first box let's give
some a try shall we
it's heaven
it's just heavenly so
it's like a pink filling on the inside
very cherry blossomy it is a
bochi
it's a small pastry with a sweet filling
and i love that they send these
feels like such a cool way to learn what
you're eating and where it's from and
how people like to eat it and i think an
especially cool part of that is they
partner with snack makers in japan that
are over like 100 years old japan
exclusive shipped straight from japan
obviously straight to your door it's
just such a like a really cool exciting
thing to get every month and i really
like the way that they support um
japanese snack makers bakers tea makers
it's it's really neat so if you want to
try out box soup
which you totally should use my code and
link to get 10 off your own authentic
japanese snack subscription from boksu
don't miss out on this delicious snack
journey through japan outside of that
weirdness which i wonder if like a lot
of other halo fans feel i'm not sure um
it's a strange one again just not
something i usually experience
yeah there was i thought the pacing was
good i liked the action in the first
episode for the most part i thought
there was some bad cg i thought there
were some bad performances um i
i thought some of the plot and the
premises were interesting like there was
some interesting stuff in there but it
ultimately just came to me as a thing
that i was like okay
this comes across as like just kind of
another cheap ish is how it came i'm
sure it's very expensive but it looks
cheap or feels a little bit cheap sci-fi
show
and i don't feel like i need to watch
that
with the halo name or not i just don't
feel like i need to watch that
um there are so many other tv shows that
i should be watching and i keep watching
the nerdy ones because
of course i do it's the way loving ips
works
even if they aren't very good i'm like i
should watch succession and yellow
jackets and all of these great shows
that are winning awards um that exist
outside of the ips that i love and yet i
keep trying to sit through the bad you
know the not so great video game ips and
i'm like i just i'm just gonna not on
this one i'm just gonna not i'm gonna
accept that this is
i i feel like almost intentionally a
sci-fi show for people who like sci-fi
shows
and not
a halo show for halo fans and that's
okay um
that was my biggest takeaway essentially
full warning i feel like i start talking
about spoilers a little bit more
specifically after this point you have
been warned
some spoilers following so for other
things that i didn't love about it um i
feel like some of the dialogue was
strange like a little bit robotic
uh awkwardly written again like your
usual kind of cheaper sci-fi show even
though this is obviously a huge
production and a huge success for um
paramount plus um yeah just some like
strange phrasing the
natural formations for the cave thing
just some odd
things that just kept taking me out of
it outside of really not liking the cg
which i found super off-putting um
i really didn't like halsey
and
i think that again trying to remove the
fandom from it is one that's like well
she's she doesn't even come across as
smart is the weird thing about it she
kind of comes across as a little bit of
an idiot if i'm being honest um you
don't have to be accurate that's okay
but to have your scientist who you're
supposed to have faith in even presented
to me as a character be someone that i
absolutely do not have faith in based on
the way that they're introduced in the
things that they say
she's like very
submissive she doesn't seem like
somebody who would like really take the
charge and finish the fight and be able
to actually commit to
you know this lengthy ai program um
but again maybe that's throwing that out
the window and it doesn't matter but
just felt like it almost made her just a
weird
character choice
overall
um i like the way the elites looked
i was cool with the way the elites
looked
again didn't love the cg but the scale
of the fights was something i think i
really enjoyed
um but it was also
i have the problem i have with doing
these videos unscripted is so all over
the place but it just feels like a more
genuine way to do it like i'm talking to
you like i would talk to any friend
about it
there were so many
things that happened that were just so
predictable again in a like classic
sci-fi tv show kind of way um
like
the girl looking at her dad i think
across the distance and there was like
she was like hiding under something he
was standing there and it was like oh
well he's gonna die
obviously he's gonna die i think it was
her dad at least you're like that's the
clearest setup for somebody to die ever
five seconds later he dies just stuff
like that just kept happening in a way
that was like well that's predictable
like i think even cheap defecting for
the girl was predictable despite it like
not necessarily feeling
that motivated um outside of this newly
introduced law that kind of implies
he's
defecting because of covenant
tech which
is not terrible by itself um
i feel like some of the scales
of things were a little bit off but
again i really do love seeing spartans
like up against humans that's so neat
um yeah i don't know i think i think my
biggest takeaway
is mostly just that it feels really
strange it just feels really strange it
feels strange to have this halo tv show
hyped for so long
and then to watch it and to see the
things that i know in front of me and to
recognize them and to like feel like
they're there because
the words had to be there that feel like
the show was absolutely not made for me
it feels like it's made for
a completely different audience who just
likes his sci-fi show
not for a halo audience um i'm sure
there are loads of halo fans out there
who again are going to get really mad at
me for saying this but that's just how i
came away from it um and yeah i've
ultimately made the decision to not
watch further episodes because i keep
watching
tv shows hoping they'll get better
rather than just watching really good tv
shows like i'm taking too much time
where i could just be watching
consistently very good tv shows so i'm
not gonna do it
i watched the episode
some stuff was cool but for the most
part
you know just i just was sort of like
why it's kind of my takeaway it's not
like i thought it was terrible nothing
like that um
yeah almost confused
if anything with with the the approach i
do think tv show writers should be
allowed to have creative freedom and
should not have to stick exactly to
the lore of games that could be so
limiting and so restricting and create
boring generic like repeatable stories
uh but in this instance it just felt
so different that it may as well have
been a completely different ip i think
was my takeaway it may have had a may as
well have had a completely different
name on it
um i was also super surprised that he
took the helmet off in the first episode
let me tell you
i did not see that coming
it's fine
i get you got to get it out of the way
again it's not really my chief
take your helmet off whatever i did not
expect them to do that i thought that
was super surprising so
yes those are most of my very rambly
unedited thoughts
as i would say it to any friend who
asked what i thought rather than doing a
structured review because i am not a
reviewer um
i think i'll probably now i haven't
before recording this video because i
just wanted to like take the time to
think about myself but probably go now
like
check out what people are saying i'm
ready to watch other videos to get other
people's impressions to see if like
maybe i can even quantify my own
thoughts a little bit better
but for now just yeah just feels like a
sort of generic
sci-fi show
that did have some premises i thought
were interesting but not interesting
enough
um
and it just didn't feel very halo
overall which is fine just means it's
not for me
and that's okay i'm not in the business
of watching
like okay sci-fi shows that's pretty
much it so
i hope you all enjoyed this video i'm
sorry that i don't feel super positively
about everything all the time but i
don't
that is it for me today i will see you
guys next time